♪ ♪
>> Tucker: IT IS THE 25TH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE
FOX NEWS CHANNEL, WE'VE ALREADY
SEEN THE GREAT PROMOS THE
CHANNEL HAS BEEN RUNNING ALL
WEEK.
TODAY IS THE DAY WE GOT ONE OF
OUR FAVORITE PEOPLE AT FOX TO
ASSESS THE LAST QUARTER-CENTURY
BUT WE WANT TO TAKE YOU BACK TO
THAT DAY.
THIS WAS 25 YEARS AGO TODAY, AS
IT STARTED.
>> WE HAVE REACHED THIS MOMENT
WHERE WE CAN FIRMLY ANNOUNCE THE
STARTING OF A FOX NEWS CHANNEL
AND A MUCH GREATER EFFORT TRYING
TO BUILD UP FOX NEWS IN EVERY
AREA.
WE NOW SEE A CLEARLY DEFINED
AUDIENCE IN NUMBERS FOR CNN.
I THINK YOU'LL FIND AS MORE NEWS
CHANNELS AND PARTICULARLY OUR
NEWS CHANNEL APPEAR, THE
AUDIENCE WILL INCREASE GREATLY.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS BEFORE IT
EVEN STARTED, THAT WAS IN 1996.
NOBODY THOUGHT THAT WAS GOING TO
WORK IN THE NEWS BUSINESS, I
WORKED AT THE COMPETING CHANNEL
WHICH HAPPEN TO BE NUMBER ONE,
IN THE ROOM THE VERY FIRST DAY
THIS CHANNEL WAS GOING ON THE
AIR.
I WAS COVERING BOB DOLE FOR
PRESIDENT.
IN THE ROOM, THERE WAS NOT A
SINGLE PERSON INCLUDING ME WHO
THOUGHT THIS WOULD WORK.
ANOTHER NEWS CHANNEL, REALLY?
BUT IT DID WORK AND IT WORKED
FOR A COUPLE OF IMPORTANT
REASONS.
YOU HAD REALLY SMART AND REALLY
COMMITTED PEOPLE RUNNING IT.
ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE WAS
ROGER AILES WHO WAS THE CREATIVE
FORCE BEHIND A LOT OF WHAT YOU
SAW ON THE AIR, HERE HE IS.
>> WE AREN'T STARTING UP A
REACTIVE NEWS SERVICE IN ANY
WAY, OUR JOB IS TO BE OBJECTIVE.
WE WOULD LIKE TO BE JOURNALISTS,
WE WOULD LIKE TO RESTORE
OBJECTIVITY WHERE WE FIND IT
LACKING.
WE EXPECT TO DO FINE BALANCED
JOURNALISM.
>> Tucker: A LOT HAS BEEN SAID
ABOUT ROGER AILES, I'M NOT SURE
HOW MUCH WE CAN ADD TO THAT
OTHER THAN TO POINT OUT THAT MAN
UNDERSTOOD PEOPLE, HUMAN NATURE,
TV TALENT BETTER THAN REALLY
ANYBODY.
THAT TURNED OUT TO BE MASSIVELY
IMPORTANT.
OVER THE YEARS, THE SINGLE MOST
IMPORTANT QUALITY, THE QUALITY
THAT HAS ALLOWED THIS CHANNEL TO
CONTINUE AND THRIVE FOR A
QUARTER CENTURY IS COURAGE.
THE BELIEF THAT WE ARE DOING
SOMETHING IMPORTANT BY LETTING
PEOPLE TALK.
SUZANNE SCOTT AND JAY WALLACE
RUNNING IT DAY TODAY, THE ONE
THING THEY HAVE IN COMMON
ADDITION TO BEING NICE PEOPLE AS
THEY ARE TOTALLY COMMITTED TO
THE FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
DID THEY AGREE WITH EVERYTHING
WE SAY ON THIS SHOW?
WE HAVE NO IDEA, THEY'VE NEVER
TOLD US.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THEY HAVE A
PET ROCK, UNSHAKABLE BELIEF THAT
THE FIRST AMENDMENT IS REAL AND
THEY ARE THE LIVING EMBODIMENT
OF ITS.
YOU CAN TELL THE TRUTH ON
FOX NEWS